pushing for parents to decide if their
kids should mask up at school that was
the goal of a protest held earlier
tonight thanks for joining us here at 11
i'm denise valdez and i'm brian loft is
close to 200 parents protested outside
of ccsd headquarters near decatur and
sahara orco mano was there he joins us
live with those parents and what they
had to say orco
well brian and denise those parents at
the protest were loud and clear they do
not want their kids to be forced to wear
masks at school they say it should be
their choice instead
parents protest against mask mandates in
clark county schools my kids don't all
mask they won't be masked close to 200
people made their voices heard wednesday
night outside ccsd headquarters
statewide guidance issued last week says
k through 12th grade students in nevada
must wear masks when they're inside a
school and on a school district bus one
woman tells us she's homeschooling her
kids this year because of that it's
child abuse to stick
a face diaper over a child's mouth that
cannot regulate its breathing and all
that properly
the power to parent union which
organized the protest says masks are a
barrier for special needs students one
size doesn't fit all that's why they
believe the choice to mask up should be
given to parents they're the ones who
are in charge of health decisions they
know their children the best and they
should be able to choose whether or not
to get them a vaccine and get them a
mask we don't want to co-parent with the
governor but other parents agree with
the mass requirement i think it's a very
practical measure krista whitley says
masks are a great way to keep her two
kids safe not every child can be
vaccinated and it's the most common
sense tactic
to
minimizing community spread
[Music]
[Applause]
still the parents protesting say their
minds are made up i do not take my child
anywhere where it has to wear where they
have to wear a mask
protest organizers tell us that they
want governor sysolak to hear their
message but it's unlikely that policy
changes will happen anytime soon by the
way there can be exemptions for some
students to the mask role if those
students have medical conditions or
disabilities reporting live in las vegas
tonight orca mana 8 news now